war es zwei einzigen da hinten dicht
machen würde da wenig ins gewicht unsere
waffen einer leine kapiere ich habe mich
aber schön lässt du auch deine juli hat
ja selbst schon mal gemacht ja natürlich
habe ich akustisch willkommen bei einem
neuen videos gibt ja leute ich habe
heute mein bruder bei der liebe
alexander geprägt also nicht wundern
wenn ein bisschen böse ist ja wir haben
auch nicht mehr so viel zeit aber
überein und auf jeden fall bist du halt
alleine
wir machen was ganz besonderes und zwar
habe ich eine wundervolle idee ich war
auch früher im tanzkurs und habe
wirklich so ein paar sachen kann ich
auch also dieses das ist sowas nochmal
auch ehrhoff nach ganz allein hier die
heißesten biskup fox gar nicht kennt
keinen sommer und foxtrott kann ich und
weiter und so also habe ich mal
kontinents minister okay auf jeden fall
hat er mitbekommen ich war ja bei let's
dance dabei wenn ihr zweitletztes
rausgeflogen mein bruder edward immer
noch mit aber ein paar sachen von diesen
vier wochen die ich es wird getanzt habe
wir sind wir natürlich auch im kopf
geblieben ja und darum geht es heute
also high court zeigt mir die krassesten
tanzschritte jeder gelernt hat und ich
bin mal gespannt ob ich das umsetzen
kann weil dort gesagt das war schon echt
schwer das immer so ein mega als er muss
ja vorstellen 819 stunden am tag
trainieren und das die ganze woche lang
bis so viele leute heute das ist die
heutige video idee ich bin gespannt wie
ich mich an stelle bei micro also bei
heike munro man was man jetzt sagen
bei denen kommt auch ein video oder ist
schon online das müsst ihr euch danach
auch anschauen und napster oder let's
dance jetzt erwarte ich freue mich noch
kurz umziehen
sogar alex weiter will zum ziel kommt
raus ziehen wo sie jetzt ein paar sachen
überlegt ja nicht wundern ein paar von
den sachen am anfang vor allem diese
noch richtige tanzschritte am ende für
sich einfach mal irgendwelche kopf ist
wichtig um zu machen und deswegen hat
existenz das dritte zu verkaufen
mal gucken wie das cloud also nicht
wundern wenn es am ende ein bisschen
komisch aussieht hätte ich da so oder so
es ist keiner von 1 bis 4 sind sondern
drei der tribute der jury saß wir sorgen
fall der können sie keine einzige zahl
richtig sein sollen
das war da ist merkur mega super nett
vor allem und immer bestens christa das
genau ist so ja auf jeden fall
wir widmen uns heute einige tanzmusik
julia boden hause selbst wenn vergießen
müssen wir noch aus weil sie haben schon
einige sachen ich kann auf mich ein
bisschen so gewinnt man kann sich auch
ein bisschen locker machen diese weise
zeigen ein paar grundkenntnisse und
damit meine ich nicht das was so
nachzudenken
also ich stelle jetzt war ich habe die
ganze schöne tanzpartnerin machen und
machen jetzt die ersten schritte weiter
trotz der 2
auch die aufgaben trainer sodann kann
ich halt so machen und nach vorne und
das ist manchmal so daneben hat geht mal
wieder zurück und dann kann man sich
auch zu drehen
erst anfang juni also ich habe mich bei
der sache das war der zwischenstand
zufrieden und lasse denn ich bin kein
tanz profi und ich bin ich bin kein
transco wie also wenn ich hier
sprücheklopfer ich dass wir eigentlich
ganz erlauben sollen wir so erwartet man
ist also nur räder auch so ok also ganz
gut hier alles gut das experiment eine
ganz andere art also was man machen wir
halt mal haben wir hier nicht haben ja
nur jackson würde sich im grab umdrehen
kann man damit den unterschied machen so
michael jackson und da alex
[Applaus]
einfach so kannst du weißt einfach das
macht aber die drehung
ich weiß nicht einmal vorbei sagt wir
können ja sagen übrigens mir fünf
verschiedene sachen weil so kleine alles
macht was sagen normalerweise denkt man
tanzschuhe ja wenn sie sich anwalt ich
habe was davor waren es ist sehr groß
geworden
ja weil wir sind nationen bis in den
queen-besuch magath zu sein ist unter
darunter wie die klinik am ring
je mehr eingelegt nicht genau demnächst
abdrücken typ 356
jetzt mache ich einmal das alleine
610 grenze gar nicht so schlecht nicht
stimmte
es ist das den wert anzupassen dass ich
ihm das ist und hat gerade sein
in den export kommt kurzer distanz aus
geflogen bin aber ich hab keine so wenig
punkte zu bekommen
das heißt denn er sich punkte auf 90 ich
hatte es 25 grad
im vordergrund steht das heißt doch noch
das wirst du eben da auch immer sagen
aber straße folgen
na ich hoffe ja irgendwie eine richtung
so regan wie man irgendwie so
[Musik]
danach machen wir doch seine füße sei
die füße jetzt wissen müssen die so wie
chili vor eine dame freut sich nicht so
sehen was macht sie das kenne ich was
macht sie du hast das vorgestellt weil
das immer besser ausgebildet seien
das ist wichtig weil datei afrika tänzen
müssen die füße überaus zufrieden sein
du malst jetzt mit dem linken fuß so
hierzu mal vor als wäre das ist richtig
du trägst du vorhast dann könntest du
rib rob treten und wir alle lange stück
losließ in den boden das ist der grund
der grundschritt diese konzentration
[Musik]
wenn ich die zeit passen können über die
richtige form in die kommentare
schreiben
ich kann es besser und ich will jetzt
gar nichts richtig aber dass der
standardtänze war nicht so recht wir
haben war einfach austreten kurs schon
jetzt fertig weiß man nicht selbst
vertreten wir auch gesagt es gibt keinen
preis so muss die manila war der spaß
braucht keine trinke ich habe jetzt drei
mal gehen wir sehen die schafhaltung
irgendwas mit dem frist befestigen kann
schulter an schulter
hier das ist eine haltung zu halten
wieso ist ja auch prosa derzeit hier ist
dann würdest du nicht so halten können
dass ich hier immer bei dir ist hier am
rätsel ist ja ich muss mich erholen wird
untersagt okay der mann muss die frau
bei der tat gesehen du musst nicht hört
78 1 kossler irgendwie soll ich das
jetzt so schnell macht mir sagst du
guckst du willst ja genau das war schon
jetzt gut europe ortet hinter der kamera
[Musik]
was macht würde da wenig ins gewicht
unsere waffen einer seine kappe ich habe
mich aber schön letzte auch kleine juli
hat ja fast schon mal gemacht ja
natürlich habe ich alles gut geht als 22
[Applaus]
mio
es ist ein sogenannter partner beruf in
dem sie dann muss jeder haushalt dass du
nicht siehst
ich kann das wirklich nicht siehst weil
die fluglinie mit dem wirklichen zahlen
aber gar nicht auf 2129 partnern ich
dachte jetzt konnten
[Musik]
so wollte ich bin jetzt bisschen nach
hinten arbeiten ich habe ich habe diesen
chips zu wissen glaubt weiss wieso ja
weil ich selbst ja ich dachte jetzt
kommen noch nicht inzwischen mut und ein
konzert voller schräger zweiten paare ja
auf jeden fall bei 12 so sahen es zu
wenig bei 14.000 gleich sagen immer
kommt noch ein paar 2 auf jeden fall
feiern egal war trat dann aber mit
handschuhen und ihr outfit aufwerten und
du bringst mir aber zwei zu tanzen wie
soll ich dir was beibringen
ja ich weiß ich werde okay leute jetzt
schon auf jeden fall bei den beiden
arten scheine vorbei sap getränk und
wenn ihr das album noch nicht bestellt
auf jeden fall hat das live album das
heißt herr gott seit ihr habt keinen
sieg heraus und ist noch tour im oktober
wird der du bist jetzt an die daten
allerdings nicht mit dir eine
konzertkarte nicht bologna check auf
jeden fall das video hatte habe ich ein
getränk leute das war's danke hat spaß
gemacht